la country has been ou tendance pour le
savoir rendez vous dans un bal organisé
à plaisir samedi dernier drapeau
américain concert live de musique
compris on est tout de suite dans
l'ambiance et pour le folklore les
participants n'ont pas hésité à enfiler
chapeau de cowboy et santiags une vraie
plongée outre atlantique parmi eux on
repère ornella la plus jeune
participante du bal voici deux ans
qu'elle a découvert l'a compris et pour
elle pas question de danser autre chose
j'ai fait de la danse modern jazz mais
je préfère la country est sûr que c'est
beaucoup mieux cette passion ce sont ses
parents qui ont transmises membres de
l'association cours berriat dancers ils
l'emmenaient aux soirées ouvertes aux
non membres tout de suite elle a
accroché et ce n'est pas s'en étonner la
présidente du club c'est cette danse et
toutes générations
franchement on a des enfants des 20 30
ans des 40 50 et 60 jusqu'à soixante dix
huit ans donc c'est franchement pour
tout le monde d'abord commence un tel
engouement que tout le monde a envie
d'en faire aujourd'hui on ne compte pas
moins de huit associations dans le
département ornella aimerait bien plus
tard se rendre à nashville dans le
tennessee pour découvrir les origines de
cette danse en attendant d'en avoir
l'âge elle participera le 22 juin à la
fée de feucherolles